la fédération des entreprises des dom a
fait nommer dans son caddie avec son
président jean pierre philibert
actuellement de passage chez nos bonjour
monsieur philibert bonjour la fedom qui
s'interrogent sur ce que 2019 apportera
au niveau fiscal social et puis sept
zones franches d'activités au nom
imprononçable lasfargue on y reviendra
mais tout d'abord jean pierre philibert
ce que veulent en premier lieu les
entreprises c'est de la visibilité
savoir on va début 2019 est est-ce que
le cap est assez clair pour le monde
entrepreneurial
alors il est clair en ce qui concerne
les dispositifs des dalles
investissements des fiscale à
l'investissement qui sont essentiels
pour nos territoires
puisque nous avons obtenu en fin d'année
dernière que la défiscalisation et le
crédit d'impôt soit prolongée jusqu'en
2025 30 the politics à ses palaces et un
accès voter tous que c'est voter
jusqu'en 2025
donc c'est déjà une première bonne
nouvelle et puis vous avez évoqué la
zone franche nouvelle génération on y
reviendra plus on va y revenir c'est
aussi une bonne nouvelle donc on a un
petit peu plus de visibilité par contre
concernant les exonérations de charges
c'est-à-dire la compétitivité et l'aide
à la compétitivité de nos entreprises
il ya encore beaucoup à faire la feuille
la copie rendue par le gouvernement
n'est pas satisfaisante et à dire que le
crédit d'impôt pour la compétitivité
l'emploi cet avantage fiscal qui
concerne les entreprises qui emploient
des salariés qui équivaut à une baisse
des cotisations sociales ça pourrait
être revu corrigé en place et alors
d'abord vous c'est bah oui nous espérons
que cette année le gouvernement
acceptera de revenir sur ce qu'il
appelle les effets de bord c'est à dire
que le dispositif qu'il a mis en place
pour remplacer le fameux cice crédit
d'impôt compétitivité emploi n'est pas
aujourd'hui à la hauteur des attentes
des entreprises
les autres louise hall quoi les
entreprises elles veulent tout
simplement avoir un niveau de
compétitivité égal à celui de leurs de
leurs voisins dans les territoires les
plus proches de nous je rappelle une
chose essentielle
on dit souvent on aide les entreprises
or ce ne sont pas des aides qui sont à
des entreprises c'est simplement des
mesures de compensation des handicaps
permanents de nous
territoire je les rappelle l'éloignement
les micro marché et les risques
climatiques et on s'excuse sadorge en
plus d'argent tout ça c'est moi plus
d'argent c'est simplement une mise à
niveau
nous ne voulons pas plus nous voulons
être à égalité de concurrence avec une
entreprise métropolitaine bon eh bien il
faut compenser ces handicaps permanents
donc la discussion n'est pas terminée en
a qu'un le gouvernement là dessus le
gouvernement que vous allez revoir sur
des thèmes qui font parler par exemple
en ce moment la vie chère par exemple
vous avez un mouvement social en france
oui qu'il ressemble parce qu'on avait vu
en 2005 est revenu en spray
c'est un des objectifs du gouvernement
lutter contre la vie chère mais je crois
que c'est un objectif commun partagé par
tous
la fedom peut proposer croix là dessus
alors la fedom sur la vie chère d'abord
attend que le gouvernement puisque nous
sommes en co construction soit un
écosystème avant sur un certain nombre
de sujets sur lequel s'est le plus le
flou le plus absolu le gouvernement
décline à l'envi depuis quelques
semaines octroi de mer égale vie chère
je rappelle qu octroi de mer c'est aussi
la protection de la production locale
alors que veut la fedom concernant
l'octroi de mer justement la fedom veut
que dans nos territoires
il y est encore et toujours de la
production locale
s'il n'y a pas de production locale dans
les halls ton ça veut dire que tout ce
que nous consommerons sur nos
territoires sera importée c'est à dire
sera transporté et donc va générer des
coûts qui vont être des coûts beaucoup
plus important que ce que l'on connaît
aujourd'hui
donc une façon de lutter contre la vie
chère
c'est de permettre à la production
locale dans toute sa dimension de
continuer à produire de continuer à se
développer tout le monde peut bien
comprendre que ce qui est produit en
martinique et qui consommaient en
martinique coûte moins cher que ce qui
est produit ailleurs et qui est
transporté jusqu'en matinée puisque vous
en parlez avec un brin un brin
d'inquiétude quand même qui ne comprend
pas ça à la il nous faudrait des heures
d'émission pour essayer non mais c'est
une méritoire qui ne sont pas d'accord
sur comment faire c'est l'état qui qui
veut toujours voir alors un peu les deux
tous les territoires ne sont pas
d'accord entre eux on a
baboo je vais expliquer que tous nos
territoires sont extrêmement différents
la réunion n'est pas la martinique la
martinique n'est pas la guadeloupe n'est
pas la guadeloupe
donc on a parfois des positions qui
permet différents mais tout le monde
s'accordent sur l'idée qu'il faut
protéger protéger permettre à ce qu'il y
ait une production locale de qualité
alors ensuite l'octroi de mer il a un
autre avantage ou un autre défaut il
protège la production locale mais c'est
aussi une ressource pour les collectivés
locales dont on vient de rappeler dans
votre journal que certaines étaient très
endetté et du coup ne paient pas les
entreprises délais de paiement est aussi
un de nos sujets majeurs pour 2019 donc
on voit bien l'ampleur de la difficulté
si on dit le prof mer c'est la vie chère
et qu'on supprime ou qu'on modifie
l'octroi de mer comment on compense pour
les collectivités locales et pour la
production locale qu'est ce qu'on fait
donc le noeud du problème se trouve à
paris
comme souvent comme toujours mais ce que
nous souhaitons c'est que paris soit un
peu plus éclairés parce que les
entreprises les élus on en pense et nous
dire ce matin de ce philibert que paris
ne comprends pas cette histoire d'octroi
de mer vous savez j'ai de plus en plus
et je connais maintenant depuis quelques
années le j'ai le sentiment qu'il
connaît le moindrement l'émetteur et le
récepteur qui joue pas sur job là oui
mais il ya un buzz au milieu on sait où
il n'est pas clair et que ds que vous
avez le sentiment que les politiques
sont claires depuis des années sur les
autres maires moi j'ai le sentiment de
plus en plus dit ce matin que nos
politiques ne savent pas défendre nos
dossiers
je ne dis pas ça j'ai dit simplement
alors d'abord
en un peu de mieux on a des
parlementaires qui sont un peu plus
présent à paris et certains se battent
bien non la vraie difficulté c'est qu'on
a une administration centrale et
quelques politiques au plus haut niveau
qui n'ont pas forcément une connaissance
très éclairé des outre mer on m'a posé
la question il ya quelques jours menace
que le président de la république est ce
que vous êtes content qu'ils voient les
maires d'outre-mer
et oui tous ceux qui vont lui permettre
d'avoir un peu une connaissance qu'on va
lui expliquer comment ça se passe dans
les outre-mer c'est bien mais pour
parler de l'économie j'aurais préféré
qu'il voit aussi des entreprises d
outre-mer donc dans quelques jours nous
allons lui demander très officiellement
d'être reçu jean pierre philibert note
bien compris ce matin que vous suggérez
au maire de se rapprocher du monde de
l'entreprise pour mieux expliquer les
choses au gouvernement oui bien sûr mais
d'accord non je préfère quand même que
ce soit le monde de l'entreprise qui
explique en direct sans passer par les
par les maires le les réalités
entrepreneurial au président de la
république
les forts galore saint prononçable je
sais pas comment vous faites les zones
franches d'activités nouvelles
générations nouveau dispositif étendu
sur un territoire plus grand c'est quoi
comme nouveauté franchement ça oui c'est
d'abord imprononçable sauf disait un
humoriste après un petit ti punch ou ça
passe mieux pour prononcer les choses
alors c'est une zone franche
alors la nouveauté de ces zones franches
nouvelle génération d'abord c'est
qu'elle se substitue à toutes celles qui
existaient auparavant il y avait un
méli-mélo de zones franches
je n'ai pas prononcé je suis on n'a même
pas fait le l'évaluation de tout ce qui
existait auparavant ailleurs passe déjà
nouveau système ben vous avez raison
d'être sur dix ça c'est le lot habituel
on passe de dispositifs à un autre sans
avoir véritablement évaluer les
précédents alors il ya quand même du
mieux dans cette zone franche nouvelle
génération d'abord parce qu'elle n'est
plus limitée dans le temps elle a plus
si vous voulez la date de péremption la
date limite donc elle est maintenant
père est enfin pérenne jusqu'à ce qu'une
autre loi éventuellement en décide
la deuxième chose qui est intéressant
elle n'est plus géographiquement
sectorielle donc vous n'avez plus à
regarder avec une loupe
si à schoelcher de tels côté de la rue
on est en zones franches d'activités de
l'autre côté on n'y est pas donc elle
est sur l'ensemble du territoire de la
martinique et des autres territoires et
donc le seul critère aujourd'hui c'est
le secteur d'activité il ya des secteurs
d'activités qui sont en zone franche on
va peut-être en parler d'autres qui n'y
sont pas ou plus et c'est le seul
critère
et puis j'ajoute que les avantages
d'être en zone franche
on était haut
rehaussée puisqu'on est revenu au taux
de 2009 ce qui est une bonne chose
bah alors la nouveauté pour nous en
martinique ce serait quoi l'apparition
de nouveaux de nouveaux secteurs comme
aller au hasard le nautisme et la
plaisance wazers nous apporter quoi
alors je j'espère que ça va apporter
beaucoup
quand on regarde aujourd'hui les ags du
développement économique de la
martinique vous avez naturellement car
les cultures traditionnelles la banane
la can j'espère qu'elle perde dureront
longtemps parce qu'elles sont
aujourd'hui des productions de très
grande qualité mais c'est pas forcément
l'avenir
aujourd'hui nous avons un département
qu'ils le libèrent comment que la can et
la banane ne représente pas l'avenir
sinon je repense que l'excellence de la
can et l'excellence de la banane parce
que ce sont aujourd'hui des secteurs qui
ont fait beaucoup y compris dans le
développement est compris dans la
recherche
vous savez la banane martiniquaise je
pensais pas qu'on en parlerait ce matin
mais il faut la saluer c'est celle qui
au monde utilisent le moins de
pesticides le mois dernier deux mois de
folie side on nous vend de la banane bio
en france en provenance d'un certain
nombre d'autres pays qui n'ont pas
forcément cette même démarche
environnementale hanche est vrai qu'en
martinique on a peut-être aussi connu le
pire avant donc ça peut être aussi un
site
mais bon je souhaite que ces khandan un
produit d'excellence mais faut pas se
lier sûr ça va continuer mais
aujourd'hui vous avez le constat il est
quoi en martinique population qui baisse
et qui baisse extrêmement rapidement on
a le taux de déclin démographique le
plus important de france et la
guadeloupe est pas loin derrière
donc il faut qu'on fasse quoi il faut
qu'on ait des jeunes qui reste sur nos
territoires et pour que ces jeunes
restent sur nos territoires il faut bien
qu'il y ait des filières de nouvelles
filières d'excellence qui leur
permettent de rester quelles sont ces
filières du nil bleu l'économie grill
économie bleue l'économie à l'économie
bleus dans toutes ses dimensions
l'économie verte l'excellence
l'excellent si on a des entreprises
notamment dans le secteur du du duduk
des nouvelles technologies du s2j qui
sont extrêmement performante
lorsque la fedom a décidé de faire son
immense travail de simulation pour
discuter avec le gouvernement sur les
exonérations de charges sociales nous
sommes appuyés
une entreprise d'excellence qui nous a
aidé à mettre en place les logiciels et
le moteur de recherche développement et
cette entreprise c'est une jeune
start-up martiniquaise on n'est pas les
chercher en métropole en visite en
martinique qu'on a trouvé donc on a ces
filières d'excellence et puis nous
sommes un territoire magnifique
vous avez une mère exceptionnelle vous
avez une capacité à avoir accueillir des
plaisanciers à accueillir autour de la
mer autour des marines a naturellement
un grand nombre de 2,2 d'entreprise un
grand nombre de touristes et c'est ce
que nous permet de faire la zone franche
de l'activité
les activités du nautisme sont
maintenant des activités qui sont en
zone franche tout le monde est d'accord
là dessus et tout le monde était
d'accord là dessus
écoutez gt il y a
48 heures aux marins où nous avons
rencontré à la fois les élus mais
également tous les professionnels du
secteur du nautisme
je crois que j'ai trouvé un enthousiasme
d'abord parce que on parle pas là de
promesses c'est du concret c'est du
concret ça a été voté en loi de finances
alors il va falloir aller un peu plus
loin dans d'autres domaines j'y
reviendrai sur la croisière notamment
mais en tout cas aujourd'hui c'est du
concret donc moi j'ai vu des projets
dans une marina on m'a expliqué ce qui
allait se passer comment on allait faire
les choses c'est quand même exceptionnel
je rappelle berlise emploi tout cela est
belle c'est le seul objectif c'est
l'emploi
quand on crée une activité de noël quand
cette activité se développe si les
touristes viennent si les plaisanciers
bien si on arrive à faire de la
réparation navale
un vrai sujet dans nos territoires ça va
créer de l'emploi
jean-pierre philidor jean pierre
philibert un président de la fide invité
dans son caddie ce matin merci d'avoir
été avec nos bonnes journées
merci majoré merci à tous
[Musique]